celebrating this man like I know I'm not
my boss my husband but like for real
I've never met a more inspiring human
Allison holker praising her husband
Stephen boss twitch on his 40th birthday
tragically just months before he took
his own life I have Louie's husband in
the entire world back in September the
couple's friends turned out to celebrate
twitch's Milestone birthday
you're an amazing man I'm so grateful
for you as the crowd watched Allison
spoke from the heart telling twitch how
he touched the lives of his loved ones
that a more inspiring human every single
day I wake up grateful to be next to
this guy who's just pushing himself to
be better pushing himself to be a better
husband and father and man every single
day
[Applause]
I've ever met you yeah because you're
like really cool you're more inspiring
yeah
Hollywood was rocked when news broke of
twitch's shocking death I've only met
him a couple times he was always full of
life and seemed like such a light law
enforcement confirmed to E.T twitch died
of a self-inflicted gunshot wound on
Tuesday
and in the aftermath tributes continue
pouring in Jody Sweden shared her
condolences her daughter and twitch and
Allison's daughter are close friends
have you reached out to Allison at all I
have I just texted her I just wanted to
know she's left it's such a talent and
such an amazing warm wonderful heart he
will be great in this now everyone's
turning to Ellen DeGeneres
well I don't want to say goodbye days
after twitch's death the comedian posted
a heartwarming Montage to her Instagram
that was my initial love for him was we
just bonded over learning to dance
together
[Music]
picking up
the special tribute first aired as part
of the talk Show's a big send-off
earlier this year over a decade ago I
met someone who changed my life and and
our show and I'm talking about you
twitch come here
Ellen hired twitch as her in-house DJ in
2014 later naming him an executive
producer I count on him to to look over
at and make silly jokes and and he's my
pal you know he's my sidekick because
you know we have this we have this
connection so just looking over and and
he makes me laugh he really really makes
me laugh she is like
quite literally kind and Ellen tells
fans that all she wants to do is
remember all the love and laughter they
had together she writes he brought so
much joy to my life I know he brought
joy to yours too I love you twitch
and you know how much we we tell each
other that every day when we say goodbye
after the show we both say love you
he says love you much and I say love you
[Music]